timing in strategy there is timing in
everything
timing and strategy cannot be mastered
without a great deal of practice
timing is important in dancing and pipe
or string music
for they are in rhythm only if timing is
good
timing and rhythm are also involved in
the military arts
shooting bows and guns and riding horses
in all skills and abilities there is
timing
there is also timing in the void
there is timing in the whole life of the
warrior
in his thriving and declining in his
harmony and discord
similarly there is timing in the way of
the merchant
in the rise and fall of capital all
things entail
rising and falling timing
you must be able to discern this in
strategy
there are various timing considerations
from the outset you must know the
applicable timing and the inapplicable
timing
and from among the large and small
things and the fast and slow
timings find the relevant timing
first seeing the distance timing and the
background timing
this is the main thing in strategy
it is especially important to know the
background timing
otherwise your strategy will become
uncertain
you win in battles with the timing in
the void
born of the timing of cunning by knowing
the enemy's timing
and this using a timing which the enemy
does not expect all the five books
are chiefly concerned with timing you
must train sufficiently to appreciate
all this